[موسيقى]
مدينه هرر المصوره هي نتاج حضاره عريقه في
زمن ما قبل الاسلام ونعتز بها كثيرا وترمز
الابواب الخمسه لصور هذه المدينه لاهم
المقومات الاساسيه في الاسلام وهي اركانه
لكن تعود نشاه هذه المدينه بعد الترابط
القوي بين ابناء العمومه لامراء هرر في
منشائهم الاساسي وهي هارلا واتفاقهم
لانشاء حكومه في مدينه هرر الحاليه
هؤلاء هم من اتحدوا واتفقوا على انشاء هذه
المدينه قبل الاسلام
واجدادنا هم اول من قبل الاسلام في شرق
افريقيا
[موسيقى]
الهرريون القدامى كانوا هم اول من استقبل
الاسلام في سنواته الاولى وبعد ذلك
وبالتحديد في عام 405 هجريا في يوم
عاشوراء من شهر محرم اجتمع علماء هرر
واعلنوا ان هرر هي عاصمه سلطنه عدل
المقامه في شرق افريقيا امتدادا من ذليع
الى مدينه مصوع وضمت تحتها قبائل الصومال
والعفر واجزاء من المناطق الساحليه على
البحر الاحمر وكانت بذلك اول مملكه
اسلاميه في شرق افريقيا اقيمت بطريقه
سلميه ومن غير حرب
[موسيقى]